man I gotta be honest I was disappointed
in Godzilla I mean he apparently is a
woman he lays eggs
he doesn't even breathe fire Matthew
Broderick is popping jokes every couple
minutes that movie was disappointing I
gotcha
Godzilla the 2014 version is directed by
Gareth Edwards in the stars Aaron
taylor-johnson Bryan Cranston Ken
Watanabe David Strathairn elizabeth
Olsen big cast of very talented people
in this movie and I was extremely
excited to see it because um
it's Godzilla that's really all I have
to say but my childhood was actually
very rooted in Godzilla
I watched the original one a lot when I
was a kid I loved Godzilla vs.
Mechagodzilla and Godzilla vs King Kong
and Rodan and all those movies I watched
him over and over again I had all the
VHS tapes I've loved Godzilla ever since
I was a kid and even when I was a little
kid I did like the American version then
I grew up and realized it's really not
that great thus I was very excited for a
more realistic take on the character of
Godzilla because that's what this movie
is promoted as a more grounded take of
Godzilla and they definitely
accomplished that very well in this
movie without getting too much into plot
details we have Bryan Cranston who
definitely believes this is a real thing
that is happening the government is
trying to hide from people Ken Watanabe
is researching it Aaron taylor-johnson
plays Bryan Cranston son in the film and
they kind of all come together as a core
to try to figure out what they can do
about certain things that are rising up
out of the earth and this other thing is
rising up out of the earth and how they
can make this all be okay for the
millions of people on earth while these
giant things are now walking around this
movie was epic and I don't use that word
too often because it annoys me it's an
overused word people are always like oh
that was epic really ever is that thing
that they're calling epic actually epic
Godzilla was epic this is an incredible
looking movie I mean I'm not just
talking about CGI this movie is directed
extremely well the shots are
breathtaking there are moments in the
movie where my mouth actually dropped my
eyes were watering like the first time
you see Godzilla in this movie I was
like um
crying it was so well done my inner
Godzilla fan was extremely happy in that
moment this movie looks so amazing
though the shots that Gareth Edwards did
in this film are really beautiful he has
a very very cool way of shooting a movie
and he has a very human perspective in
regards to looking at these creatures
and that is the best way that you can
sell a giant creature in a movie is show
it from a human standpoint there's this
incredible shot in the film where you
see a character's viewpoint of Godzilla
as a human and it just sold the size of
it and the massive destructive
capabilities of this animal and that's
the other thing I loved about this movie
was it portrays the creatures in this
film as animals they're not cool CGI
monster things they're animals what
would they be doing is it their goal to
cause destruction amongst humankind
no they're just animals trying to
survive that's one of the things I loved
about this movie the more realistic take
on what would actually happen if
something like this rose out of the
ocean bryan cranston in this movie is
fantastic his performance is so filled
with emotion there just wasn't enough of
his character in the actual film i
wanted to see more of his character
because he added so much to the movie
aaron taylor-johnson in the film is a
more conventional character and some of
his human drama did feel a little bit
like we've seen this before but I do
think he did a really good job in the
movie and his character is the
perspective of the audience we
experience this entire event through him
I wish he was a little bit more of an
emotive character that you could really
get behind I do think he was very good
in the movie though and I'm not saying I
didn't like his character because I did
I just wanted a little more emotional
punch from him Ken Watanabe is always
good David Strathairn is also always
good elizabeth Olsen was also good movie
all the acting in the movie was very
realistic there wasn't that one
character that you were like yeah he's
totally over the top and he's hamming it
up everyone's taken it seriously and
that seriousness is very needed in this
movie because it's sold very
straightforward like this is happening
how are we going to deal with it the
score by Alexandre des Platt is also
fantastic I love the way this movie
sounds the sound effects the movie has a
great first act I really got behind it
then an event happens which I will not
spoil that I thought detracted from the
emotional weight of the film
and then we didn't get quite as much
Godzilla as you might expect then the
third act happened and I actually
cheered a few times like that doesn't
usually happen with me I'm usually very
quiet I paying attention and I don't
want to make too much noise but during
the third act of this movie I was
cheering I was applauding it is so
satisfying the final act of this film is
teased a couple times during the movie
and that's another problem I did have
with it and I think that some people
will have I think the major complaint
people might have walking out of this
movie is that there actually wasn't
quite enough Godzilla for a while they
tease these big fight scenes and then
you're kind of left hanging and then
finally you get some real meat and it's
awesome but during the second act of the
film I won't spoil it I won't get into
it but there was a scene that they were
setting up and then it didn't happen and
I was like oh I wish that happened
because I would have loved to have seen
that I really enjoyed the characters in
the film
I loved the human perspective of this
event showcasing how a human would deal
with this larger than life quite
literally thing that is one of the best
parts of this movie the movie is
actually very eerie suspenseful and kind
of scary there's a couple tributes I
thought anyway to Jurassic Park
throughout there and that's a very good
example I can use because Jurassic Park
took dinosaurs and made it as plausible
as it's ever been in a movie this movie
does that for Godzilla and when Godzilla
throws down in this movie I was cheering
and clapping it was awesome my only
complaints with the film are that second
act needing just a little bit more of
Godzilla being awesome all the actors do
a great job the movie looks incredible
it sounds incredible and my word the
third act is mind-blowing Lee fantastic
I'm gonna give Godzilla and a -
definitely check this one out in
theaters it is a theater experience
movie for sure but don't go into this
film expecting Pacific Rim what I mean
by that is don't expect a monster throw
down every few minutes because you will
be disappointed this is more like the
original Godzilla film where there's a
lot of nuclear sub plot and subtext to
the movie where it has a lot to say
about mankind's view of nature that is
definitely the main themes of this movie
the more frightening aspect of mankind
and nature not so much let's see
creatures fighting you know what I mean
so if you go in this movie expecting
that you're going to be disappointed
what you think of Godzilla if you saw
the film
very interested in knowing what you
thought because it's Godzilla and I kind
of want to talk about it because it's
awesome thank you so much for watching
as always guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes